declaraciones europeas de brazos
abiertos a los refugiados está el bloque
preparado para el influjo creciente de
personas ya nos acercamos al millón
y esto parece que va a continuar dado
las cuestiones operativas
ha advertido eso el consejo noruego para
los refugiados también y el comité
Internacional de la Cruz Roja
con comunicado especialmente apoyando a
los diferentes países también europeos a
hacer de alguna manera a dividir esta
tarea para apoyarse entre todos y así
apoyar correctamente a este flujo de
desplazados vulnerables obviamente en
graves situaciones de vulnerabilidad que
están pasando por la frontera de Polonia
Pero eso no quiere decir que queden en
colonia sino que van a tener que hacer
un plan integral
para poder apoyar debidamente a todo
este grupo en situación de
vulnerabilidad que más que nada son
mujeres niños y personas adultas en este
sentido mira y otro tema es la crítica a
un manejo racista de la crisis no solo
por las denuncias de mayor dificultad
para los afrodescendientes en sus
intentos de evacuación sino porque hay
puertas abiertas pero ucranianos frente
refugiados que por décadas han oído de
la violencia en países africanos esa
hora tiempo para librar también esta
discusión
Me parece que no es el momento para
liberar esta discusión en una en una
situación de conflicto armado tan
pensionado como está en este momento y
con las bombas literalmente cayendo en
varias ciudades de Ucrania el momento Es
que la principios humanitarios de no
distinción ante la violencia y la cojo a
la población civil sea total un anime y
que esto abarque como dije antes
muchísimos organizaciones que están en
este momento en el terreno y los países
que van a hacer la acogida a esposa
tanto todos los sectores están
diferentes razas como también diferentes
religiones mira y finalmente rápidamente
le pregunto qué opina usted desde el
anuncio de macron es que prevee a
a niños huérfanos de la guerra es
adelantarse mucho a los acontecimientos
o llega en buen momento
me parece que es un poco adelantarse a
los momentos no creo que haya en este
momento tantos niños huérfanos hay que
esperar son 6 días nada más va a haber
obviamente huérfanos hay solo por lo que
los reportes están hablando ahí solo no
hay muchísimos son 2000 personas que han
muerto pero
se entiende que la familia ucranianas
están tratando de acoger a los huérfanos
también ellos y que no pierdan su
identidad que eso también es importante
en todo lo que tiene que ver con el
desplazamiento a través de los
diferentes conflictos armados que
lamentablemente el mundo está viviendo
en este momento más que nada el de
Ucrania que por lo que se ve en esto
Solo 6 días casi un millón de
desplazamiento forzado de población es
un número muy alto
y celebro la declaraciones de Francia y
espero también que latinoamérica esté a
la altura de las circunstancias cias